-Performing "2010"
from his new album, "Sick,"
give it up for Earl Sweatshirt.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[Rapping] ♪ Huh ♪
♪ I'm-a need a bigger bag
for the cohort ♪
♪ Tryna make a millionaire out
of slum dogs ♪
♪ Bet that, head crack,
blunt force ♪
♪ Cozy with the east Africans
up north ♪
♪ Seven make a three,
turn a ten by law ♪
♪ Crescent moon wink,
when I blinked it was gone ♪
♪ Left the crib, smacked,
no sheath on the sword ♪
♪ Made it by the skin
of my teeth, thank God ♪
♪ '03, momma rockin'
Liz Claiborne ♪
♪ Had her stressin' up the wall
playin' Mary J. songs ♪
♪ Rainy day came,
couldn't rinse the stains off ♪
♪ Long way to go,
we already came far ♪
♪ Story stayed the same,
it was never made up ♪
♪ Threw me loose change,
look at what I made of it ♪
♪ When the mood change,
I'ma poker-face 'em ♪
♪ It's a new day,
who got all the aces? ♪
♪ Who be foldin' late?
Who know when to play dead? ♪
♪ Who sit up straight
when the roof caved in? ♪
♪ Had a full plate,
you ain't wanna split it ♪
♪ Tell it to you straight,
you ain't wanna listen ♪
♪ Cup runneth over the brim ♪
♪ Bust open,
there's no closin' the lid ♪
♪ Drumroll,
here go my lil' entrance ♪
♪ Gung ho,
I'm the one that go get it ♪
♪ Five O's on me
like the Olympics ♪
♪ Pure gold, somethin' told me,
"Don't mix it" ♪
♪ Caught a feelin', momma had me
out Temple ♪
♪ Not religious, we was really
out Philly ♪
♪ Livin' on the fly
tryna wing it ♪
♪ We got us a fire to rekindle ♪
♪ Redirect the fight
where it's meant for ♪
♪ Triumph over plight
and immense loss ♪
♪ Ride alone at night,
I get clear thoughts ♪
♪ Caught a couple slights
and I veered off ♪
♪ Saw another height,
had my ears poppin' ♪
♪ Walked outside,
it was still gorgeous ♪
♪ Sharp incisors reveal slowly ♪
♪ In the dark inside,
we was real hungry ♪
♪ On a seven of the five,
♪ We still drummin' ♪
♪ Foot shook ground
when I stepped on it ♪
♪ Didn't look back
when I broke soil ♪
♪ 'Cause every time I did it
would hurt more ♪
♪ In the dark inside,
we was real hungry ♪
♪ On a seven of the five,
♪ And I didn't look back
when I broke soil ♪
♪ 'Cause every time I did it
would hurt more ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]